hello everyone and welcome to the other
game I promised I'd show you from the
women's section of the American Cup it
is uh a woman Grand Master in the
international master and Nazi pakija
versus Freedom Master Alice Lee and um
and we know that Alice is already in the
finals against Irina Crush but that
means she had to win the semi-final
match and this is how she did it uh her
opponent is uh two times the girls world
champion four-time European girls
champion and two-time uh women's uh US
champion so uh definitely a dangerous
opponent so let's see how she overcame
this obstacle first game where Alice had
the white piece was a draw a fighting
draw after some 70 Moves uh this one is
uh much much crazier so let's check it
out we have D4 by Nancy uh sorry that's
not a d form uh D4 and now Pawn to D5 by
Alice with C for C6 going for the slav
defense Knight to F3 and Knight to F6 uh
Knight to F6 with Ponte E3 and the
bishop to F5 the Shalom defense Knight
to C3 with E6 and not Knight the H4 just
going after the bishop Bishop G6 and now
and as he captures it with captures
captures and Bishop to D2 so these are
these are all uh standard moves the the
absolute Main Line Knight beat the D7
with Queen to C2 and of course Rook the
C8 nicely aligning The Rook with the
queen Pawn to C5 uh keeping the C file
closed and now uh there is a very cool
game uh from 2016 I believe uh from
between Lauren fresenay and Daniel dubo
of that fresen A1 it was from the
European individual Championship he had
the white pieces uh and here Daniel
continued with Queen to C7 but here we
have Bishop to E7 by Alice and it is now
as of move 10 that we have a completely
new game so here we have uh Pond G3 not
going for Bishop to D3 which is uh uh
what you would expect but upon the G3
probably preparing Bishop to G2 and
Castle's King side uh but uh you would
think Ponte E5 by Alice and now not
Bishop to G2 but instead Castle's Queen
side she gives up a pawn uh for uh an
attack and advantage or over the H file
as you'll see Knights to G4 now
threatens Knight characters on F2 to
Fork the two Rooks so of course Bishop
to E1 and now Rook captures on H2 we
have Rook characters Knight captures and
not just the bishop to H3 now the bishop
will move and The Rook will come to H1
and uh hopefully uh gets to the back
rank uh we have Pawn to E4 closing off
this diagonal and now Pawn to F4 not
allowing uh e captures on F3 Alpha song
because of Queen captures and H2 so you
have to move the Knight as the Knight
here is hanging Knight to F3 and now
Bishop to F2 keeping the bishop pair and
she's hoping to utilize that H file to
her Advantage with Quinta 5 now and Rook
the H1 as planned we have rooked the C7
and now comes Pawn to G4 here a bit of a
safer option with just Bishop to G2 or
G4 just going uh after that Knight and
now after black tries to dispose of
white strong Center you are faster
Bishop capture spawn captures and now
the immediate E4 and if B captures on C5
you play e captures on D5 and if C
captures on D4 you have this nasty D6
move and if Bishop captures now comes
Queen to E4 with check and after Bishop
blocks now you're gonna capture on D4
and white mobilize the all of um uh her
forces so here uh okay let's say queen
to B4 and it's still it's still very
sharp but that's uh much safer than what
happened in the game in the game and
that's in Nazi played played uh G4 we
have B6 now Alice is faster here on the
queen side C captures and B6 we have
Knight captures and B6 and now Bishop to
G2 uh so basically going for the uh for
the same idea only with the inclusion of
this G4 move we have Knight to C4 now
putting pressure on the
uh B2 pawn and now comes Rook the h8
with check with King the D7 and now you
would like to play Bishop captures on F3
but it's hard to see if it's possible
Bishop captures an F3 Rook B7 goes after
the B2 pawn and now you have to play
Queen A4 you have to trade queens and
after captures captures now you will
take back on F3 and this is what what
you would get so it's definitely
possible in the game however Rook the B8
was played as stopping Rook to B7
altogether and we get this very very
interesting position where there is only
one move that gives Alice advantage over
the position and it's not an easy one to
spot so feel free to pause the video and
try to find the absolute best move for
black while I give you a couple of
seconds
foreign
to do it congratulations on being a true
master of positional play and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Rook the C8 uh forcing a rook
trade because this Rook is just too
annoying on on B8 so here you have to
trade uh Rook captures we have King
captures so really congratulations to
everyone who found this and now Bishop
captures an F3 e captures and pawn to E4
uh she's breaking through the center
here but now comes Bishop to B4 and
there's just too much to worry about
here there's uh no good way to continue
you would really love to play e-captress
on D5 but it's insufficient for example
if he captures on D5 C characters on D5
and now let's say Knight captures on D5
uh with the idea that if Queen captures
B3 you're gonna win back the Knight on
C4 there's Bishop to D2 check and after
King B1 now Queen captures and after B3
trying to win back the Knight there's
Bishop captures on F4 and now it seems
okay yeah you you're just gonna trade
down you're only going to be down upon
the problem is Queen to B7 check the
bishop covers the C1 square and if King
A1 Queen to B4 and there's just no
defense the thread is Bishop to D2
followed by Bishop to d uh C3 check uh
you're not going to be able to defend
that so your only option is to trade
Queens but now the end game is
completely winning for black yes only up
one Pawn but it's too easy to play after
let's say King D7 King to B1 or King to
B2 uh you will play F5 and that's it you
either allow captures in G3 or you
capture in G5 lands and it doesn't
matter if you if you bring the king
closer into the position G3 and want to
offer a trade of Bishop's Pawn to F2
threatening F1 Queen and if King E2
you're just gonna trade captures
captures F1 Queen and you are completely
winning so that's why uh Nazi does not
have time for E captures or for f
captures on e4 she goes Knight to B1 but
that could be even worse Queen captures
on A2 with e captures on D5 now C
captures and F5 we have pawned the G5
and now Pawn to F6 trying to create some
counter play here Alice doesn't allow it
you just play spawn to G6 and now Bishop
to E3 you could also consider something
like B3 to offer a queen trade
uh but uh uh Alice would very happily
trade Queens here so Bishop the E3 was
played as the Knight cannot move and now
just King to D7 with the idea of
capturing the bishop Bishop characters
and G5 and here are most spectacular way
to finish the game is possible for Alice
uh there are many winning moves here but
the bishop characters on G5 is what
makes possible the one that she goes for
uh and she plays Queen captures on B2
offering an entire piece but it is it is
not possible to take advantage of this
uh specifically because of the bishop
and G5 now you you can't really play
King to D1 so Queen captures on B2
Knight captures on B2 and now you don't
have King captures because of F2 and
there's no stopping queening because if
Knight the D2 Bishop just captures it so
uh you're gonna play something else
Knight the D2 was played right away but
still just Bishop catras King captures
and now Knights the C4 with check King
to E1 and now Knight the D6 and this is
what I meant by it it's possible because
the bishop is now on G5 you don't have
King F2 uh because Knight the E4 check
picks up the bishop and G5 so here after
Knight to D6 Bishop back the C1 was
played uh but now Alice is in time to
play Knights the E4 and now the white
king is completely boxed in uh by the
Knight and by the pawn you cannot uh
approach it and the bishop can never
touch the pawn as it's on a light square
and to make matters worse after Ponto G5
F to check was played and now it was in
this position on move 38 that Nazi
pakija resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so first
game ends in a very fighting draw after
70 more second game goes to Alice and
that's how Alice got to the finals the
face Irina Irina crush and here you
resign immediately because after King to
F1 yes now you can get to the pawn but
there's the other problem the past AFA
Pawn now upon the A5 and okay you go
after the pawn Ponte for you even
capture the pawn Ponte 3 and now the
pawn is Unstoppable your own D for Pawn
is in the way so after I have to check
she resigned and a brilliant brilliant
victory for uh for uh feeding Master
Alice Lee uh we'll see uh what she does
in the second game against Irina in the
finals uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it once again
congratulations to everyone who founded
Rook to B8 Moon uh Rook to see it Moon
not an easy uh idea to find I would like
to thank Mike Wagner thought dreams uh a
very nice video yesterday Ryan Cavanaugh
and Henry Spraggins for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day